hey everybody and welcome to an informed
wild ride with stevo we have the new
host of jeopardy this week miam bialik
and of course she's known for being the
star of blossom many other things and
she knows a lot she shares a lot and she
spills the tea plus
stay tuned because it gets intensely
personal too
now
i think that she's got a lot of good
advice as well like she says that people
are eating way too much salt and way too
much sugar these days and i could not
agree with her more
that's why it is so important to me to
enjoy my magic spoon cereal
this stuff is the solution to
wanting to eat like an absolute jerk and
just pile your face with sugar and just
awesome tasting cereal but this cereal
has zero grams of sugar per serving
only four carbs grams of carbs per
serving and 13
grams of protein come on dude this is
like health food that tastes just like
that guilty pleasure that you enjoyed
when you were a child and magic spoon
believes in their product so much it's
backed with a 100
happiness guarantee if you don't love it
you get your money back i love it man
and
i really need to back off the sugar once
again i had it big time sugar relapse
and i'm leaning on magic spoon to help
me get my weight under control again i
think you might want to give it a try
too and i've got a deal for you you go
to magicspoon.com
stevo and that's gonna get you five
dollars off your order and you can get
this trial kit it comes with your fruity
your frosted
your cocoa
and your peanut butter i mean come on
you can't go wrong the stuff is
delicious and it's actually good for you
so go to magicspoon.como
and for good measure use the promo code
stevo when you're there to get five
dollars off your order and find out how
absolutely delicious this healthy cereal
truly is
take it from me you're gonna love it now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen mayam
hello hello so nice to meet you it's
very nice to meet you inside of your
tour bus yeah thank you and you've met
paul briskey
scott randolph yes hello um so
this this is great thank you for doing
this thank you for having me
and and you're the official host of
jeopardy now i i'm sort of i'm
i'm the um i'm one of two people
finishing out this season of jeopardy as
a host and um
i don't know more yet if i did i would
talk about it right right right um but
not necessarily your professional i
could also be lying to you but in this
case i'm telling you that i'm not um
but uh you know i kind of live from
season to season as a sitcom actor and
so jeopardy has fallen right into my
schedule of not really knowing what i do
past any particular may um so i will
basically be working you know i'm on
call me cat which is the um sitcom that
i work on i'll be on that introduce i'm
i was right i mean they give you that
credit but basically i'm you know
an actor who sometimes says like what if
i do this um but once that ends i will
finish out the season of jeopardy um
but ken basically does the episodes that
are recorded when i'm at call me cat so
all right that's ken parson ken jennings
and jenny's on jeopardy he was the guy
that like won the most money ever right
yeah
he's the winningest yeah how do you get
a job being the the host because do you
are there some words that you don't
understand you're reading it in real
time yeah well so keep in mind you're
watching an edited
and edited show meaning if i mess up
pronunciations all the time you know on
average five things per episode we have
to you know re-do so when it all comes
together like it looks like oh she
pronounced i mess up things all the time
um sometimes i mess up totally normal
words that are in the language that i
was raised speaking just because it's a
lot of words and you're talking for i
mean hours and hours and hours so just
sometimes your brain gets slower than
you know the words trying to come out
and so yeah i was always impressed with
alex like he'll just read a french word
i'm like how does he know he's a french
canadian okay an italian word
he was good you know he was just i read
italian words okay i do pretty good the
one thing that is hard for me is french
like you know um if something's well i
i'm a spanish speaker so like if
something's in spanish or even i know
italian is not the same thing as spanish
but it's those like but french there's
letters that are there for no apparent
reason and i don't know how i'm supposed
to know not to pronounce some and you do
pronounce others so french is the
hardest for me and you know i think
everyone knows that
i've often found it difficult to be
around french people
the french canadians especially those
are the worst the worst of the french
wait i have a question with jeopardy
when they say like let's go to the
judges
yeah
is that one guy sitting there is that
like a room full of people like looking
up stuff you know this is a group
and are they giving you a thumbs up like
what is that there's a lot of thumbs ups
that happen because
so i mean there's a whole art which is i
think it's so fascinating like how
a show like jeopardy is constructed like
the number of pieces and opinions and
things that go into everything like
every single clue
so for certain things they'll already
list other acceptable answers for things
where a couple answers are acceptable or
they'll make a note if like oh if they
say this they need to be more specific
right so i'm like learning those things
but sometimes they'll come up with
something and i'm just like i don't know
and so yeah there's a i have a light
that turns green if it's a go and it
turns red
they're looking at a camera that's very
close to my face and i do not have a
poker face like you know i'm like a
cartoon character like you see every
thought that happens so they can tell if
i'm like uh you know and then i'll i'll
get the but yes there are judges we
sometimes shut down for close to an hour
over one wow you know one decision so
you don't see that you just see that
like oh they rule on this but any
episode where we correct someone's score
like the judges have ruled that mahogany
is also an acceptable tree that begins
with an m or whatever it is
that usually means we've shut down for
like an hour wow but as you played on
the show it was just like judges yes
correct
after review we're adding you know two
that happened and um we just had the the
college you know championship and that
happened where it was like it was like
literally mahogany some tree and uh
yeah and it it can change the course of
the game and you know i mean i saw the
movie quiz show i know how intense
there's a lawyer on set all day a lawyer
from standards and practices
it's there to imagine going to law
school
and you get placed
they just sit and make sure that
everything's kosher and you know a guy i
went to high school with ended up on
standards and practices
at dancing with the stars
and he was in charge of making sure that
i had uh covered up the tattoos on my
knuckles which said [ __ ] and [ __ ]
wow that's that guy's job yeah was that
his only
does he have to make sure it's not like
too sexual right in general
that fell under the umbrella
you can still see the eye right there
[ __ ] went in a little bit deeper
you don't miss those tattoos i loved
them
you know it's crazy that uh i wanted to
say how my mom and i used to bond over
jeopardy and she was so good at it i
mean like i it was just an exercise in
me losing every time but uh but but we
loved it and also um my mom the last
time she laughed was when i showed her
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on my knuckles she said
my son is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh yeah i lost my mom in uh 2003.
um
but yeah she just she was great she
loved jeopardy it's really really cool
what an institution oh i mean it's yes
it's its own legacy
you said that jeopardy falls into kind
of what your norm was with sitcoms which
was living season to season but having
said that you did pretty well with shows
that
made it from season to season
um
yeah thank you you know i i definitely
yeah in that sense
this kind of job or potential job is
different you know than being an actor
like there's so many more
things at stake for a company when they
you know try and decide like who's the
face of this brand you know also like
being female
right you know it's like it's very
different you've never had that so
that's you know different um
you know i didn't grow up seeing anybody
that looked like me on television much
less in the streets of the city that i
lived in so it's also like it's kind of
cool to be like a quirky person who has
always been super different um and to
get to kind of be you know on a very
mainstream right you know thing like
it's
it's kind of cool and scary but mostly
cool
it's super cool yeah um with uh
with um
like television kind of
feeling like it's going the way of the
dodo is uh is is there a
streaming platform that that is sort of
propping up
that for a jeopardy you mean yeah yeah
like i think that's probably you know
beyond my
scope of you know business understanding
and things but maybe maybe i'm
completely wrong no i think i think
that's sort of you know when i was you
know originally hired you know to work
as part of the jeopardy family um
i was doing the i was basically brought
on to host like the primetime stuff and
in theory if other things go on and into
streaming places um but you know due to
all the things that happen um you know i
ended up moving more into the syndicated
role but um
people really like to watch jeopardy
yeah like it's a very i watch it on
youtube while i drive yeah wow
all right so there's that
probably should be focusing on the road
people do
people watch it they watch it like live
like a lot of people right right i wanna
watch that so
um
you know it's it's one of those kind of
american television institutions you
know it almost falls like in the sports
category a little bit where you want to
watch it live and like exactly outside
of the realms and i think
because it's on every blessed night you
know it's kind of like it's not the kind
of thing you catch up on on the weekends
like you're kind of either in it or
you're not right and then if there's
like a long you know a long-running
champ like you know like we had amy you
know that that'll happen that people you
know like you want to see what happens i
mean here's the thing like
every game feels exciting to me because
i'm getting to watch in real time like
three people super excited and
competitive and like holding information
that like i have no idea how they know
all the things yeah it's insane it's so
impressive it's another level it's not
even like you could be like oh if i
you know start learning no these are
people their brains are they're special
they're wired to hold that i'm not smart
enough to remember to say what is after
before you ever said this
imagine having to remind people of that
and like tell them it's wrong in double
jeopardy if they don't say it it's
actually considered a wrong answer you
got to make it in the form of a question
this is very stressful though oh my my
mom had never watched jeopardy which we
found out because when my first episode
aired literally posted a series of texts
where she was like
you look amazing whatever moms say when
you're on jeopardy
why is everything in the form of a
question
that's literally what she asked me i was
like cause that's the show no no no but
what this is a text no but why is it i'm
like no the show is about you phrase it
as a question she didn't know am i right
that they always had jeopardy and wheel
and fortune go back-to-back yeah it's
actually this we share a question about
7 30.
we share a crew they're right across the
street so my my like sony credentials on
one side says jeopardy on their site
says wheel of fortune which is just kind
of cool wow so you can sneak onto the
wheel fortune set no because of covet
once covid is quote over right i'm gonna
be everywhere right i'm gonna be on the
wheels
and vanna white is still doing the
letters she's still and she's
sh they both look like the they've been
say jack they look like they haven't
aged i mean i'm sure if you get close
enough they look like they've aged but
they look unbelievable i don't know what
happens on that stage but i should hang
out there more i i heard about pat sajak
he was uh good morning vietnam that's
who it was when robin williams played
his character he was like a disc jockey
for the war it was based off a pet sajak
i could be completely [ __ ] lying
about that but
if we can confirm that i think that's
what uh i mean you want me to look it up
on my phone i know i mean yeah i mean
i'll look it up what a weird fact to not
be 100 certain about well you'd be
surprised
i just did it so we can find that out
but uh i'm gonna look it up
yeah dude paul is going to the good
old-fashioned internet to get some
accurate information which i am a big
fan of i like accurate information so
much i wear the most sophisticated
fitness tracking device known to man
it's called
whoop
and i'm telling you it's good plus
they've got the new whoop band 4.0 which
actually now keeps track of my blood
oxygen my skin temperature i mean this
thing is incredible i get all the
information that i could ever want about
what's going on with my body from how
well i'm sleeping how much time i'm
spending in each different stage of
sleep to how many calories i'm burning
precisely which activities i'm doing to
burn calories i'm sleeping better i'm
getting better rest i know how hard to
push myself on any given day because my
whoop app is telling me this whoop app
membership is the best thing that has
happened to my fitness in years and i
want you to try it especially because
the new woop 4.0 is so awesome it's got
the waterproof charger slides right on
top so i never have to take it off it's
always bringing in data to let me know
how to
maximize optimize my fitness so now i
can get you 15
off your membership and if you're a new
member you get the whoop 4.0 brand
banned absolutely for free with the
membership i mean all you got to do is
go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
com and use the promo code stevo at
checkout for 15
off of your membership and again new
members they get the whoop 4.0 band
absolutely for free and that does come
with the waterproof charger so take
charge of your health
get in the game man rest better work at
better play harder do it all better
and it's at whoop.com with the promo
code stevo now let's see what we learned
so going back to to your acting went
like
the uh
your first gig was
1987.
yeah um so that would mean maybe would
have made you like nine or something no
no no i started let's see i started
acting when i was 11
in 1986 and i was cast in a horror film
uh pumpkinhead
it was a stan winston movies tariff like
i couldn't even see it it was that
terrifying i didn't like horror movies
pumpkinhead pumpkinhead yeah it's a real
classic from the vaults i mean i i think
i have like three lines i was like
wallace kid number five um is that one
of those cult classics that people yeah
like in the yeah in in those arenas like
i have a friend who's super and he's
like oh yeah you were in pumpkinhead i
know that like okay and then i was cast
in beaches about a year after i started
acting and i played the young bette
midler and then after that i did blossom
from 14 to 19.
and then i left the industry i you know
went to college and grad school i had
kids and then i came back um did big
bang theory for nine years and then i've
been on call me cat
how does uh leaving the industry
like that's uh
you know i mean you think of child stars
and and so often it's like a really
tragic story about how like
you know all of a sudden the
entertainment industry was finished with
them and then everything went sideways
and uh and so you finished blossom and
you were like okay i'm good now i'm
gonna go to college and become a
neuroscientist um
i mean like the the short answers yeah
kind of you know i i come from an
immigrant family like my grandparents
are immigrants and so like i was taught
you go to college like it's what you do
right um you know especially as a woman
like if you don't have to be
cleaning the floors of the house that
you moved into because you married this
dude and you're his property go to
college like you know if you have a
different life take it so um i was two
years out of high school and blossom
ended and um yeah i was definitely um
you know not really like a holly like i
wasn't really comfortable in hollywood
it like i wasn't really interested in
like the fame part of it that was really
intimidating and um i wanted to go to
college i wanted to like be judged for
you know the work that i did with my
brain and not just sort of what money i
could make for whoever um i had
had an amazing
tutor for biology when i was on the set
of blossom and i fell in love with
science i was not a natural science
student it was very very hard and you
know it was difficult all the way
through grad school like i wasn't that
kind of brain that was like i got this
like it was very very hard the whole way
through
um i did five years undergrad i did a
minor in hebrew and jewish studies and
then um
i met the person that i ended up you
know dating for five years we got
married we had two kids i had my first
in grad school
and i went straight to a doctorate
program in neuroscience um
and i had my second son and then we were
running out of health insurance because
this is america
and um i figured if i can just get like
enough acting work just literally to get
some insurance like i was teaching
neuroscience i was tutoring piano i was
tutoring hebrew like i had a baby
strapped to my chest and was like i was
out you know like i didn't know what
size clothes i wore just like whatever i
put my hair was like i had like long
hippie chick hair i was living you know
my best life i didn't have to wear a bra
if i didn't want to it's great um and i
had never seen the big bang theory like
it was one of the first auditions i went
on when i kind of like tried to start
auditioning again
um
and you know it was a guest spot i was
in the season finale of season three of
big bang
and then you know nine years later
you know i and in that time i got
divorced you know
my dad died like my kids got older you
know it's like a whole other life you
know right um so like not what i was
planning and also amazing
right
um
with that that you said a doctorate in
neuroscience
is that
different from medical school yeah so um
i didn't have the grades to go to
medical school that's the god's honest
truth there's a class called organic
chemistry and that is the class that
decides if you go to med school or not
and i could not i mean i think b minus
was like the highest grade i was able to
get in you know the full year and a half
of organic chemistry i had to do um
i ended up going to graduate school
that's a doctorate um so what that means
is you there's like a core curriculum of
graduate work in neuroscience which is
neuroanatomy and and you know
biochemistry and molecular neuroscience
and all those things and then you do
rotations you work in a laboratory and
then you choose a field of study and a
doctorate is um original research
meaning research that has not been done
before um that you do um over a period
of time of your graduate work and that's
why it takes um about six or seven years
for my department um
and i had let's say i did two years of
course work then you take qualifying
exams um i had to do remediation on two
because i just there's a certain way of
thinking and communicating that doesn't
come naturally to me i'm not a natural
scientist
so it was definitely a slog and then i
had my first son after i finished my
coursework was in data collection i
studied obsessive-compulsive disorder
which is a real hoot um i have that
really bad
do you
i won't ask for your blood or your spit
there's different kinds his way is more
like he has to respond to emails oh
which that's the compulsiveness so yeah
but i'll like i'll say something and i'm
like did i really say that i don't know
second guess like something somebody
told me that's a that definitely i'm not
i'm not formally diagnosing but yes that
will occur on that spectrum that that
road caster that's recording all of our
sound would probably get checked 300
times in the course of a podcast to make
sure it's still on
all right so we're moving into moderate
ocd
you want to give me another one
when i when i was younger you know when
you're driving in the car and then
there's the line and then the bumps on
the street i'd have to like point my
finger in between everyone so what yeah
okay so you're my people so what um what
what happens if you don't
uh
nothing what does it feel like
well i've gotten over to the point where
we're like uh you know i can i can work
it out and i won't but like do you feel
like oh the earth might end like
well well now i guess if i don't respond
to an email it's just like it looks so
bad yeah
you know but hey did pat sajak ever get
back to you on that question
pat sajak was a dj in vietnam but he is
not the one that that movie is based on
there was a show called dawnbusters with
a dj named kroner and he would start
every show saying good morning i like
your story better okay yeah yeah we'll
cut that out one more ocd question do
you have a number
no
my no
number six i'm not like a number ocd
person but we have to like turn the knob
four times no like people well so i you
know i lived my whole life just being
the person i was and it wasn't until i
had a psychiatrist who asked me some
very specific questions that i realized
oh my god not everyone does this that
was
he was assessing me this was i was in
college and he was like
do you have a number and i was like of
course i do he's like tell me more and i
was like well
so i didn't know that not everybody has
i was like yeah i count breaths i count
steps it's like and he's like oh okay i
have to touch things yeah
three is mine i like nine because it's
three three three um but i thought
everybody has a number and counts their
breaths and steps and he's like
just very special people like you
wow and so that went and that's why you
became a neuroscientist so it's it's
it's funny no
and also that's the field of study i
ended up with because i'm a vegan
neuroscientist and that means the
research the choices for research if you
don't want to work on animals are quite
small
um so one of the one of the choices of
human labs you know that you can work in
in my department if you don't want to
work with animals um was a lab studying
the field of mental retardation and like
prader-willi syndrome was the syndrome
that i worked with and they have very
high rates of ocd so that's i studied it
in this particular population wow
is that different than what you did when
because steve had drugs tested on him as
a human yeah i uh
signed up for a medical study for
fda approval oh
and i mean anything that's ever going to
come in contact with the human body they
have to test it for sure and uh if
you're testing a toothpaste you might
get like 10 bucks yeah yeah yeah
i had uh drugs for pigs and cows tested
on me so i got two grand
wow yeah what were the drugs supposed to
do it was supposed to increase the
muscle mass and decrease the fat
of cattle
to
the 80s to the world to a more health
conscious consumer
there's so much ironic about what you
just said
right
right did it work uh
it was gonna increase our heart rate and
the target of the study was to uh give
us the drug until somebody's resting
heart rate was over a hundred and fifty
people no that doesn't feel yeah it was
dangerous and that's why uh they paid so
well the more danger the more money
that's what i always say yeah and it
came right in i wanted to be the gnarly
crazy guy so that's just like right in
the narrative that i was trying to spend
what was your heart rate do you remember
mine never went over 90 i don't think
right like uh mine does one like
before i go up on stage
i make him open for my shows and his
watch tells him his heart rate is like
don't do that today 169
170. isn't that good for you it's like
exercising good for you
jesus i thought it's like how bad it is
getting your heart rate up you know we
need to call hr
hr
kidding me right i mean
would you normally have like a blood
pressure issue
well lately because i gained some weight
wait do not put it in am i gaining
weight because my cortisol levels are so
high i mean there's probably a lot of
reasons i don't know it's i think it's
got a lot are your cortisol levels
elevated it doesn't do that when you're
like heart rate
stress
it's a it's a stress marker i mean i
have so many questions for you do you go
to therapy i used to i probably should
i'm not going for it
i bite my nails quite a bit i'm a
chronic nail biter yeah wow good boy uh
struggle's real when you were
when you were taking the organic
chemistry organic chemistry organic
chemistry what was your right a lot was
that whole foods
was your hope to get very good grades
and become a doctor yeah i wanted to i
actually wanted to go into psychiatry
this was in an era before everyone hated
psychiatry um
i i was interested in um
really more the therapeutic side of
psychiatry um
yeah if i were to do anything i wasn't
really interested in the institution of
the medical field just because it was
the beginning of
you know what we've kind of seen it
become it's like they they're more
business people you know they have to
get like mbas at you know just to be a
medical doctor now and
just insurance is such a mess and i
think it's such a disgrace that you know
a country is wealthy as ours can't do it
but i wanted to work with people with
psychiatric conditions and so that was
actually my interest um
and so you know that kind of pivot is
like one of those moments where you're
like oh my mom was wrong i can't do
anything i want if i set my mind to it
you know it's kind of like i also
couldn't learn to be a concert pianist
at right you know 19 if i wanted to it's
just that's not how it works you know
right
um i mean i'm like i'm an okay pianist
but you can't just be like i'm gonna
make my brain do like my mom said i can
say you wanted to be a doctor but in
hindsight you're glad that you're not
yeah i mean you can still call me doctor
but you know i mean you don't have to
but no i mean i i do i hold a doctorate
it's you know a doctor of philosophy in
neuroscience is the the title of a
doctor
i'm not an md no like if you say is
there a doctor on the you know on the
plane or whatever like no
let me tell you it does not take a
doctor to tell you that you're gonna be
healthier if you drink more water right
and especially if you're drinking a lot
of soda then cut it out with that crap
and switch to liquid death sparkling
water you're going to be a much
healthier person and you're actually
going to be a lot happier too but let me
get serious for a second here because i
just learned that 75
of all aluminum ever created in the
history of the world is still in
circulation being recycled being useful
and
only nine percent of plastic ever gets
recycled and it's just creating this big
plastic monster that's filling up the
ocean killing wildlife and destroying
the world you want to know why this
company's called liquid death because
it's time to bring death to plastic
because plastic is killing the world and
liquid death is saving the world at the
same time as they're making you
much healthier and happier i love this
company i'm behind it all the way and
they are the most generous one of my
sponsors
ever because they're giving you
free shipping for your entire order of
water and merch and boxes of water are
pretty heavy but they love you so much
you don't even have to pay for that
shipping why lug water around from the
store when it can show up at your house
with free shipping man i love this
company and to get this deal all you got
to do is go to liquid death dot com
slash stevo once again that's liquid
death dot com slash stevo if you love me
if you love this podcast and if you love
yourself and or the world you're going
to go to
liquiddeth.com right now and jump on
this offer
there you go now let's hear about the
doctors
no yeah you're staying silent i mean
like i'll hold your hand and rub your
back right so you're like a sam harris
are you familiar with i was in class
with sam harris oh wow we went to
neuroscience to like to neuroscience
grad school together we were colleagues
wow did you guys still stay in touch
yeah i actually had him on my podcast he
was one of our first guests we had um
you know
there's you know we were a class of like
18 or something and and several of us
you know didn't stay as it were you know
in traditional neuroscience research
positions um but yeah sam worked in
brain mapping which is actually where i
did my undergraduate training so um
yeah
super cool sam got really into
meditation do you meditate at all with
being a neuroscientist yeah so i um yeah
i mean i'm a person who um
you know i i've
you know i grew up with mental health
challenges in a time when nobody talked
about it it was just like you know your
parents told you when you were hungry
when you were happy when you were cold
like you know it was a very different
time
um and then i you know got into therapy
and sort of started you know being
medicated in various ways you know by
the establishment i mean from the time i
was a teenager because we just like
couldn't figure out you know what like
what was wrong as it were
um so
you know my story is like a lot of
people's it's been a constant journey
you know like there's been times when i
have not been on medication um i
i am on medication now i have a lot of
mixed feelings about that
yeah medication yeah i thought you meant
you have mixed feelings about me being
like
um no but but the other things i do is i
do go to therapy i go i go twice a week
um i i do participate in um
in 12-step programs alcohol is not my
allergy but other things um are and i um
have decided to sort of break my
anonymity and i do talk about that um
about the kind of support and really the
the changes in your behavior that do
help your brain rewire in addition to
medication all the other things and uh
lo and behold meditation is one of those
things that takes care of a lot of the
somatic stuff like
you know i started having a heartburn
which like anyone living in our society
during you know i think the last 10
years you know probably has had some
freakout or reaction to anything coming
out of washington dc in any direction
and i started getting heartburn um and
uh was instructed to up my meditation or
like try and take it more seriously
so i am not a transcendental meditation
person i i do not really you know i
respect that form of meditation but the
interaction i've had is like you know
you pay a lot of money for like a mantra
and i haven't felt the need to do that
um i use a free app
that should pay me i don't you know
i'm happy for them to i use insight
timer and what it is is it's a free app
i don't pay for anything on there i mean
i make donations to you know and i just
there's like a search bar and you put in
whatever you're feeling or experiencing
even if it's like back pain and just
pulls him up and he's like oh i want a
10 minute one i want and that's what i
do i try and do a meditation at lunch at
work you know when i'm filming um like
no matter what even if it's like a five
minute one or whatever i do that
and then i i try and do one at night
also
um
yeah it's one of those things that the
the science
absolutely backs up what thousands of
years of eastern philosophy and like
it's kind of like oh here's the research
it's like you don't need the research
like this is like it's completely legit
that it completely changes the oxygen
like it it's not magic i mean there's a
mystical element to a transcendental
experience you know and i've had
experiences when not you know on drugs
that are um outside of the realms you
know i would say of quant like
quantifiable human experience like i've
experienced things that i cannot explain
in meditative states uh but again i i
don't necessarily think that there's
like you know
magic to it like it is open to everyone
to learn to breathe you know right and
that's really what you know
scientifically
you want the research what is going on
you know like when you meditate and your
back hurts but you can fix that with
meditation yeah is that because your
back hurts just because you're stressed
or be you know like i mean that's that's
like it's
this is one of my favorite things to
talk about i'll try and give it you know
like the most kind of concise like my
understanding as i've been instructed so
um
many many people have what is now kind
of collectively called in the field
they're they're calling it mind body
syndrome and what it means is it's not
in your head
you know the word psychosomatic makes
people feel like oh you think i'm lying
right
exactly right it's like toughen up right
no but if you if you've ever known
someone who has a nervous stomach and
like before a date they like
lose the contents that like have to go
to the bathroom and lose the content
that's exactly what mind body syndrome
is however for some people it lodges not
in their stomach but in their back
or it will lodge
you know in the form of migraines or you
know like there was a time in my life
when they were certain i had irritable
bowel syndrome i was just extremely
stressed in a way that my body
completely
needed to indicate
and i've you know after i moved through
that period of my i've never had it
since right but if i had taken the
classic western approach like you have
ibs
medicine this like make your life crazy
you can't eat anything anymore your life
is miserable i would have gone down a
whole other you know track
so what i've done is kind of pursue
scientifically legitimate therapy that
is it's called somatic therapy where
they work with your overall anxiety it's
often from trauma or stress
and the idea is to lower your baseline
so that you do not essentially feel
things in your body as intensely you
know people are like oh i'm an empath
like that's that that is real it's real
that some people feel things more deeply
and manifest them in their body and i'm
not saying you can
cure the cancer with your brain you know
but what we do know is that the more
we support
this kind of health the better our
immune system functions and the better
we function in general the
the shorter answer is that there's a
there's an there's an autonomic nervous
system that is in your body that you are
programmed with that teaches you to calm
down and it's something that's in
mammals like it's not it's not like a
special human thing
and that kind of breath work and that
kind of increase of oxygen and you know
like most of us don't even breathe all
the way through right we just like we
breathe with our shoulders right
everyone just started breathing right
but what it what it does is it tells the
it tells that part of your nervous
system to dial everything down like
it lowers your blood pressure like it
does all those things and that's true
it's not you know and there's people who
are like oh your brain waves this i'm
happy to have people do brain studies up
the wazoo but like that's kind of all
you need to know everyone's moving too
fast we're all processing too much
information no one has attention for
anything and nothing's been recording
this whole time
yeah
i think this camera just died though
i'll
i got that yeah
breathing
different ways can help me fall asleep
too totally yeah i mean no one feels
good when you're
breathing as if you're scared and i
remember that's actually specifically
what was happening i'm not trying to be
political but for me
when certain things were happening in in
our
last
presidential experience i was waking up
feeling terrified like literally not
even a cognitive fear i was feeling like
like something was threatening me right
it's like oh it's because i'm reading
the news like right before bed you know
and it's it that it activates you know
and some people might watch horror films
read the news like and be like totally
fine i'm not that person so instead of
me like trying to fit my life to be like
all those other people who are fine i'm
just gonna like stop watching the news
and being on social media and hating
myself all day right and lo and behold
my heartburn went away wow yeah they
said
babies breathe with their stomachs
because they're not stressed right the
humans
use their chest well yeah cause like the
world is terrifying you know
i'm i haven't taken a breath since you
asked that question geez
yeah
i'm so interested in so much of this but
with the with vegan you're like but
let's get back to jeopardy
no not at all not at all um with that
vegan
and science sort of being your your your
focus
does it drive you crazy to no end the
way the
animal rights community
twists
science and you know like
i
you know like you see these these these
various you can i'm a i'm a safe vegan
like you can tell me all the things that
bother you
what bothers me
is when you've got these vegan
documentaries which are saying oh sugar
doesn't cause diabetes
you know and it's like
wait a second you know for all the
people who are becoming vegan because of
this misinformation coming out of these
these you know vegan documentaries and
then all of a sudden and then all of a
sudden these people realize oh wait a
second that wasn't true well right so i
mean there's uh there are a lot of
vegan documentaries and also not
necessarily vegan ones but just ones
about like you know food inc and you
know things like that about kind of like
factory farming which i think everyone
should just know about like oh
absolutely um you know and i think
it you know it kind of like it takes all
kinds right you never know what's gonna
impact someone or you know make them
make a change for me like i don't feel
like i have a personal agenda you know
around making other people vegan um you
know but i know that for a lot of people
that a lot of vegans do
um and yeah i think that
the general guidelines i feel like that
everyone should be going by
is we're all eating too much processed
food yes no matter what we're all eating
too much salt and too much sugar yes and
um
we're we're not eating enough things the
way the good lord made them right the
way the earth produces them so sure
that's true for everyone and and my
thing is also like
i don't believe that everyone needs to
be vegan that's not my goal um what i do
think is that
you know we we should hold our our
government
much more responsible for the way they
help us eat and in particular you know
um
you know the notion that the cheapest
food is what is often most kind of
subsidized and which also
does tend to give people a lot of
diseases that otherwise might be
preventable you know like it that is a
shame you know but i know why people eat
fast food it's because it's delicious
right um and it is convenient and it's
inexpensive right so as long as we keep
incentivizing you know that
kind of thing and as long as that is
subsidized in large parts by a
government that's like we promise it's
good for you we're going to continue to
have a tremendous health crisis
so so i do believe that even small
things like this notion of meatless
mondays even the notion that
you don't need to eat meat three times a
day like i promise you know the and and
i think and i'm not like i'm really not
a conspiracy person but when you look at
you know kind of the the general
marketing of of meat and dairy in
particular
it's like we've it's true we've all been
told this is how it is like your teeth
are gonna fall out if you don't drink
milk three times a day is what i was
raised with right like my bones are
gonna break and i'll be laying in the
street like a boneless you know right
and that's actually not true is the
easiest is one of the easiest ways to
get calcium to drink a big glass of the
milk of another animal
yes nobody's like let me strain the
beans to get the calcium i have to eat
beans 72 times a day nobody wants that
right but to me like i don't like to be
lied to right that's why especially by a
governor i just don't like that so to me
like you can be honest you can be like
there's a lot of ways to get calcium and
here's the one that we're going to
subsidize because it's good for the
farmers
um you know and i have family that lives
and works on a dairy like i have family
in israel that lives on a kibbutz and
there's a dairy there so like i've you
know spent time there i've worked in the
dairy i've helped cows give birth like
i've done all the things you know right
pretty much everyone who works there is
vegan you know that's kind of funny
and i believe too that that with factory
farming the most
horrific
of of all of it for me is is the dairy
well i mean the the treatment of the
workers themselves should also bother us
right because any you know
like karl marx was he was right about a
couple things and when you want to make
the most product
for the least amount of money and the
most profit for the people at the top
everyone below that will suffer right
the things that are making the product
which is in this case the animals but
also the workers that are right that are
doing that work and there was a
wonderful expose i think it was in
harper's years ago about the injuries
and things that happened to people who
routinely work in these kind of
factories like the turnover is like so
rapid because like their bodies like
they're it's it's not humane
you know it's not humane to work in a
factory like that like it's it's it's
not humane for the animals or the people
what's happening people are getting like
hit with oh yeah no it's like if your
job if your job is like repeatedly to
hack with uh you know i don't remember
the thing you know like literally it's
like wrist injuries hands like all these
like elbows and [ __ ] like they just
can't work you can work there for like a
year or something and then like your
body just gives out right because it's
the rip it's this like repetitive motion
and like you know the union's like in
the whole situation with that and it's
like oh you can't get this break it's
it's nuts yeah it's totally nuts
not to mention like forced birth control
for women because like we can't have
women get pregnant it's inconvenient for
factory work you know oh that still goes
on so to be an employee you have to be
on birth control kind of a thing they're
they're i i'm not speaking to specific
factories but absolutely like i don't
mean to be such a downer i thought we
were gonna have fun but yes that is
still something and no one to me like if
you want to talk about like women's
issues this is one of them there are
women
you know in this country and beyond yeah
who
who work in places where they are
not permitted to yeah have you know free
will with their body yeah wow i've never
heard of that that's great
i i believe that that goes on
with the
tying together the
you know animal rights with the the
human
uh human rights i went to ringling
brothers and barnum and bailey clown
college i i literally need to talk to
you about that so much
i'll be happy to so much i i i i'll be
happy to do that we can do that into the
podcast my company is called sad clown
productions like a clown thing i love it
and um you know that was when my
sort of journey with animal rights began
because there was one day
at clown college that i remember they
had uh the like the pr department of the
ringling brothers and barnum billy
circus come visit us and and they said
you know some of you are gonna
become uh employed by the
the greatest show on earth and part of
and your job is going to be to promote
the circus in advance of uh of it
arriving in certain cities so that means
you're going to be doing interviews and
during these interviews there are going
to be questions that you get asked from
time to time about animals and animal
rights and the conditions of the animals
and they said in that situation you have
no answer you shut up well and they just
i mean it's been a huge revolution for
ringling
it's been a huge i think two or three
years i guess that you know um and you
know to me like i grew up i the the
first house we lived in was above the
hollywood bowl like i'm a very like l.a
you know i literally grew up behind the
hollywood bowl and ringling brothers
would set up in the parking lot across
from where we lived and at night we
would hear the animals and like that was
it was a tremendous thrill especially
for a kid growing up we didn't have any
money like the circus was actually one
of the things that we could like do you
know i remember i had like my first i
remember having like my first candy bar
it was like i remember sitting in the
stands you know across from the
hollywood bowl at the you know under the
big top like
so as i became a vegan obviously it
became
much more complicated and then like oh
cirque du soleil came to town it's like
oh for eight thousand dollars you can
enjoy a circus with no animals but like
that very quickly became cost
prohibitive yeah so the fact that like
we've had such a you know a revolution
and that um you know they've kind of
come back it's very exciting because
there is so much i believe to enjoy and
there will be people who are like what
about the good old days it's like well
it's like i think tiger king kind of
like did it
yeah
but my experience when those people said
you know you have no opinion about
animals you're a clown you fall down you
know you're not
like it is not you're not allowed to
voice an opinion about animals and and
hearing that my
my gut feeling was wow they like i feel
like we're being told that they're doing
really wrong things with animals and
that was back in 1997 and and
i ended up working you can't have the
people having opinions you know they
might rise up
right especially the clowns
i never worked for the ringling circus
but i did work for another circus that
had three animals and a tiger and my
personal experience was just that it was
awful you know i felt that like from my
perspective
the the owners of the circus i worked in
were more afraid of the elephants than
anybody else and they were very
you know they are enormous creatures
right also the largest vegan on the
planet is an elephant yeah um
yeah but those are those are creatures
that are you know they're not made you
know to
do those whether they're made to walk i
want to say 80 miles or 100 miles per
day yeah they're not made to be chained
to a post correct and
transported around on a train i mean
look this is a this is a consciousness
that we have now like remember that like
there was a like my mother was told to
smoke during pregnancy
like can we can we all just remember
like it was like it's good it is good
for digestion it's a diuretic it's a
diuretic like that's you know coffee and
cigarettes after a meal yeah it makes
you poop because it's a diuretic like so
this
this consciousness though it's it's new
and the fact is when i became a
vegetarian you know when i left my
parents home at you know 19 like people
thought i was insane right they're like
this is the stupidest thing and like
you know i'm not saying like i was right
but like i also like was like why do we
keep using plastic bags every time we go
the grocery and i had this like stupid
canvas bag
like you're nuts and now it's like oh
they're going to charge you you're going
to use a plastic bag
i love that that's a good point
back in the day it was they just didn't
really know yeah i'm going to be late
okay
we're going to continue the conversation
i'm having a great time yeah this is
really fascinating i'm really enjoying
it yeah my podcast is all like mental
health and wellness stuff but like i
cannot wait to talk to you i love it
how many episodes have you done i've
done about 80 i guess okay um and
you know it was like something that my
partner jonathan cohen and i started
during covid because our mental health
was suffering and we were like ours is
suffering and we have resources and
therapists you know like what about all
the people who are like what is this
terrible feeling in my stomach every day
when i wake up it's like oh you've never
felt anxiety welcome so we started
talking to people about um
you know what what they do what works
what doesn't i don't i mean you can tell
i'm on a journey so
so you've done you said roughly 80
episodes and are you like disciplined
like every week it goes up at a certain
time yeah apparently like consistency is
like a big thing we used to come out
twice a week but then like when the
jeopardy thing happened i was like i
can't i don't know how to keep up yeah
and we also film it i have a youtube
channel um and we hit a million
subscribers which is a very big deal so
we so we
we videotape it which means like you
know i need to like sit up straight and
like put on lipstick and you know um so
yeah so we film it and do a whole audio
thing we're like a four camera operation
we like to say we're the nicest looking
podcast yeah that's funny because we've
done like 96 of them and uh
coincidentally
the last two that we're going to do
would be you and joey lawrence oh yeah
when are you speaking oh we just had
joey we just had him yeah he was the
last one that we did what uh
with the face you're making
amazing was it just difficult to be
around him on blossoming
that's that's what they call latency
right where like you're attracted to
somebody so you're mean to them no idea
he wasn't my type oh yeah so he was all
of our types in the last thing i mean we
were sweating in there i gotta imagine
it was just physically uncomfortable to
be around him he was so attractive no i
was like a grungy feminist who like
didn't shave my legs and he was like oh
you're gross the face you made getting
all excited you just love joey lawrence
oh no i just i just love that he exists
like all of us you know like we were on
this show and it was like so iconic and
like he's like larger than life he's
like you know yeah
my sense of him is that
there are certain people who
have uh in their career done like very
family friendly sneaky clean work yeah
and not necessarily been that way but he
is that way oh no he's very yeah yeah i
mean he was raised in the industry like
really you know i watched someone give
me a break when i was a kid so
well-adjusted
such a you know just a solid good guy
really my impression that's so cool and
i think i feel the same way about you i
think uh oh sorry you know like
for all of the the horror stories of
child stars it's uh
we had a really clean set also that's
the thing we grew up on a set where we
didn't see drugs we didn't see alcohol
right um and we're very i think both
very grateful that we were we i mean
that that does make a big difference you
know we grew up on a very clean set i
think there are plenty of clean sets
that
turned out very
very dysfunctional but also like we all
went to junior high in high school some
people have a hard time with drugs
alcohol and mental illness and some
people come from homes of abuse and so
i'm sorry you know that so that happens
you know i knew kids who od'd who
weren't in the industry you know right
so
on that note thanks for having me it's
been great
good night vietnam yeah i love it
i i loved it and um anytime you want me
to do your podcast that i'm available
yeah we'll just yeah heather's um she's
in charge of all things booking and
yeah we just we just booked um seth
rogen which is really nice wow
we had matthew mcconaughey which he had
no idea why i wasn't that was so scared
like you have no idea who i am he's like
no ma'am i don't
i was like i don't know who had sex with
who to get you to come on my podcast
when you have no idea who i am but
welcome matthew mcconaughey
it was awesome great and we had a great
time with him we had a great time with
him yeah wow anyway i feel like i want
to like uh
drop a couple names of our biggest
guests oh yeah
we have to have had mark cuban
that's pretty cool
and he knew who
yeah we had mike tyson
yeah
we had post malone okay these are these
are good names yeah but but matthew
mcconaughey
maybe seth rogen don't even know who i
am
great to meet you miam
there you have it man was she awesome or
what dude i mean
i think she was surprised at how much
she enjoyed us and we were surprised at
how much we enjoyed her
and i hope all of you guys are surprised
by how much you enjoyed sticking around
to the very end of this podcast like the
street team it's been a long time since
i said street team but when i see you
guys at my shows and you tell me street
team
man i just want to give you a hug and
tell you i love you because i really
really do love you thank you for
sticking around and have a blessed day